what did mom I'll tell you what happened
here's the thing I'll pretend like I
didn't just say this before we started
that takes away from the natural well
trying to be ol disclosure and be honest
I did I did start saying okay you know
i'm saying that's being more honest than
actually i'm going to act like you like
you just cuz you went home ok so you
with acne soul pizza before i come back
you want to set this up set it up
alright here it is III don't come out
and see Dan that often right and when I
do we hang out I do talk to him all the
time so it does feel like we see each
other a lot you said hey if you if you
know dan st. germain phone call you know
how intense it is now I'm just kidding
but no yeah we're getting Shaw no
kidding like like it loosens a little
bit as he gets older like it's beside
you're like oh my god that's an old man
behind us smell I today I'm texting with
Dan and he says oh do you want to eat
because they want to eat after the
taping the podcast taping he goes like a
farewell meal and I go what do you mean
farewell meal I bet he meant like the
friendship what I did I did you were
right on that says that you were ready I
can picture dan just completely try and
change his persona after this and become
like a [ __ ] wakeboarder or something
so what happens as he goes hey man it's
your choice wherever you want to go I'll
go so I go wood ranch grill which is a
place that I love to go to in Los
Angeles put dan gets megs it's not like
a fancy [ __ ] restaurant it's like a
chain type looking place that's at the
mall it's an outdoor there are so many
levels of Sean reading into this but
I'll keep going no well no because you
gave me [ __ ] about this last time I
wanted to go to the wood ranch well that
this done in time didn't guy was
proximity yeah that was proximity so
just now he goes have a blitz shows my
friend who's Lou vanilla is Olaf uses
blitz all right well if you use that
voice you can make anyone sound [ __ ]
student so and and as such as my friend
I just went on when to Yelp and blood
says jose a higher grade than wood ranch
grill so wood ranch is very very good
anyway well I said that we I you call
me out I said we'll do it and then Sean
like an Irish [ __ ] idiot couldn't
have it like I couldn't have it he's
like no we'll leave it to luck and he's
like legit let's have a coin flip it's
not I'm like no we don't have to do the
coin flip we can just go to your stupid
[ __ ] chain restaurant no coin flip it
is so Aaron flips this coin Sean of
course pics wrong all right fine we'll
go to your again he gets in his home I
know you can't get pissed off and so
we're gonna go to [ __ ] wood ranch so
Sean got his way and you know but i did
say up front that i would go there it is
far away from my house i am working
tomorrow but find that as you can
probably guess is the final episode of
my temper in this last episode is it a
crazy time to have this last episode
because right now all the election stuff
yeah don't know well the guys are taking
the Senate and it's it's back and forth
with it with Hillary and Trump I think
that it's going to go Hillary but I'm
not totally sure tom tom is still
praying that somehow Bernie Sanders runs
in and and and grabs like on Rio Stein's
nephew yeah yeah yeahs more progressive
than yeah I'd be here yeah it's like I
wanna come Jule Stynes yoga teacher yeah
we're gonna eat your cat Barrera teacher
yeah Jule Stynes where a teacher that's
who I want to win this um I it is a sad
sad days the last time we're gonna be at
least in this format for a long time
yeah we're taking you want to call
taking a break or do you want to call
we're gonna call at the end of it
if we somehow come back then that's
great but I don't want to peel I don't
want to like angels in the outfield dad
this you know be like yeah I'll be back
yeah don't worry about it um so I mean
I'll start out by talking about i guess
the last time I'm gonna talk about a
dumb thing that's happened to me this
week at least in this format I brought a
date I was really excited about it's
been like a month we were setting up
sheet a month she was getting over X and
we went over there um I brought her to a
revolving restaurant in LA was a human
beings what what do you charge sheet in
Wall Street oh is that what he says I
think he does that look yeah but I
thought it'd be like a pot I write is a
bad idea for a day you know but the
problem is is that like like I got a I
got a phone call from my family before
that was really depressing and then I
went on this revolving restaurant Dave
so sometimes I would just stop talking
and then just look off into the distance
and then for both the city and it would
slowly revolve as we like eight these
horrible appetizers and turn turn turn
play to the be any day yeah
and then like we had an inside
marionette joke and I like sent her a
picture of a Marion at like three days
later and no response which is not a
great no tax just America oh my god i
guess i could know even though that
would be hilarious that's nice that's
the next one to her because she's not
gonna respond a week i'm just messin
marionette I can officially eyes a
malaria yeah it's just I marionette like
super imposing a picture of her family
know so that that was well the date well
let's let's backtrack here the date went
weird because well it was okay i mean i
think it was fine i mean we uh you know
it there were good things about it i
guess you know but like was their
conversation flowing or you i was having
flower in the hallways having flow
whether you like this girl maybe maybe
part of it was you didn't like her as
much as you thought you did when you got
to the date um no I liked her I mean I
don't think it's I definitely have stuff
with other girls from my past going on
which I won't get into but or grow up my
past anyway mom doesn't count and my mom
is Kim while we dated totally I made
flowers on her what am I please don't
last I'll be able to a true detective
reference lord knows I've done 57 of
them on his show so you basically left
that date feel like [ __ ] basically this
is what you've said Joseph are you like
the date you had a moments of silence in
the date when you look out the revolving
restaurant window and then they ended
you waited three days and then send a
picture of a creepy puppet was that a
great look the one maturation now that
I've had is I used to when like I'd be a
wad now am i gay I know that was not
that wasn't a good oh yeah man she knew
well you were like trying to joke around
right yeah it was uh and that's how long
ago now that you sent that that was
friday and i think i said the pic
yesterday so the day wow that is well
the thing is here's the deal was a
friday night went on the date saturday i
said i had a good time last night
nothing back two days later i sent the
marionette thing as a joke because we
talked about going going out on a
another date and involved a marionette
theater oh that's what so it wasn't
funny day the perfect
charming funny text right and then
nothing back after that so it's like
it's done it's okay I've got I'm dating
it's not I'm not I'm out there you're
doing it I'm at what they're never
arrives young you know I went on a
lovely date recently so they are not
like where'd you go we went to another
revolving restaurant but this time it's
been my thing like you kidding me you
being serious yeah that was fun too what
Dell tell me I was dating for a while
and then now I'm dating again and
Benjamin's like I know more about
restaurants you know it was fairy tales
because i was i was with this the
revolving sushi place i went we went
back to my house and then later in the
night just to like see like it's a cute
girl right you know i just want to see
how her tender work she opened a
pretender I was like I wonder what
happens like tell me if you think this
guy's cute and we were like connecting
guys for him I you think he's cute
connection boom every single like
ninety-five percent of the ones that I
said you think he's cute it matched oh
really can immediately guy like hey
what's up like a girl guys too well yeah
we were back at my place and just
hanging out and just shooting the [ __ ]
oh wow you know so okay yeah we were all
gonna die it was cat it was kind of fun
I was like I opening to just see how
much cop because these are all good
looking guys you have so much
competition in LA it's [ __ ] insane
everybody's gorgeous everybody's
gorgeous I think I saw a homeless lady
before that was gorgeous they look like
i said this before they look like
Portland attractive people yeah homeless
people at La we're going attractive it's
unbelievable they won't she walked by me
I was out I I had a lot of time to come
before this writing so I Lily was on
Sean just did at midnight again no i
didn't i do tomorrow he's due tomorrow
were you doing Hollywood center studios
oh I was there for a meeting Oh with the
people that run that cut wood that show
nice yeah yeah you know big-time
Hollywood ooh no but what I did was I
waited around and I like sad and like
the unlike the the planner outside like
waiting I was on my phone like you know
texting you and stuff like that and
everybody who I'd say eighty-five
percent of the people who pass by were
like it's really super attractive they
have to be yeah it's great have to be
like like the moms that were bringing
the kids to audition for a movie role on
the Hollywood center studios and like it
was crazy and it was like obviously the
moms were like actresses like 10 years
prior and now they're living through
their children stuff like that right
very sad and then what I get I'll tell
you what I did that was kind of dumb
kind of dumb I well first off the
something I was like I hit you up and I
go hey I'm gonna walk to the podcast you
do and you go isn't that far from me
written about how do tennis shoes and i
go no it's a half a mile it turned out
as a mile and a half that's what it was
so that's kind of dumb and i walked out
of work yet though cuz you hell ya know
i had like two and a half hours to go oh
no i loved it and then I took my time
and I was still here like an hour early
I love dinner no no I did I did I i'm
doing i'm going to gym now so I like
walking yeah yeah so basically and then
at one point I'm walking I'm walking
down and I see lights like shrimp club
type lights right and I was like oh nice
what I'll do I'll just go to the strip
club and get a beer I just said at the
bar you're here have a beer yeah and
maybe a lap dance but I mean and a beer
at the strip club yeah and then I got
closer and it was an auto body shop so
gonna lap dance there again watch
cheaper to him yeah it was kind of a
body shop it's kind of a bunny yeah yeah
what a lot of problems of the
transmission though they were extracted
mechanics very attractive McCann area
director and I went in there and I I
mean I didn't go in there I just like I
was hoping it was a strip club and then
I instead I went to some cheese and wine
shop and bought cheese this is a whole
new Sean I know I'm trying to putting
last tiny pieces of cheese Manhattan so
sure no one but himself like would
anyone like cheese he brings out a plate
no one else is touching to you
Erin's perfectly fine not having cheese
I don't want to have the cheese I
figured it was better than getting every
time I else I come here every other time
we come here I get like like chios and
like right coke and all this I don't I
haven't drank soda in like since July
that's great I'm like let me class it up
with some cheese that I haven't like
chips and whatever else you know I was
doing really um I was doing really good
and then this election because I've been
doing Brazilian jiu-jitsu that's so boy
we talked about he did we said we're
gonna fight yeah we have to fight now
that we can't fight on this podcast we
had to fight in real life we will we'll
fight physically what have you learned
so far and the thing I feel like I worry
about to take [ __ ] from co-host so what
would a fight what would we should fight
for wood ranch grill or Bledsoe's pray
tell ya right now I would probably win
because I have a wrestling background oh
my be good maybe you kidding me you
really don't actually know what I'll I
was gonna call you out for that but
you're actually probably right you did
actually wrestle on high school right I
was a only freshman year but I rest of
all middle school all in middle school
and I still made a guy tap in jujitsu so
all right so you're [ __ ] town are you
saying twelve-year-old Vantage remain
yeah as soon as I pin you lose gomez
just go sick bro his voice appears on
Louis Gomez uh we just Yanks podcast you
can check that out mmm in MMA it's
pretty it's pretty interesting man Aaron
do you know MMA stuff you follow it all
right are you watching the are you
watching the big fight on Saturday night
Oh No to be more accurate I know because
of podcasts that we have on the network
okay dude it's nuts because Aaron you
were so miserable in your job that one
was a minimal answer than you could have
given I know because some of you talk
about it it's pretty nice like how much
goes into it if you realized that yet
it's like I always thought it was just
kind of like you're rattling around on
the ground a little bit no it's like a
chess game but with ya yes absolutely
that's exactly what it is it's pretty
insane it's really interesting I almost
fought a lady I voted today and I almost
bought that I'm actually on the spider
I'm kidding but I have you voted in New
York
I voted in New York right up really
early oh dude I got up we got up at five
o'clock in the morning and then six
o'clock in the morning the polls open
and we got there and there's probably 50
people online already yeah I got seven
and it was an hour way yeah and and we
didn't wait an hour but it was like a
half hour kind of waiting to get in and
then what happens is eat I don't you
live that I don't know how they don't I
want not political it just uh I don't
know how they don't have voter fraud
these people they have working at the
[ __ ] the poll miserable not just
miserable they don't know what they're
[ __ ] doing the lady at one point
comes out there's all if you want to
line it's five in the morning people are
miserable its Queens so they're not
gonna be cheery already and literally
the lady comes out and she goes I ok if
you know your ETA your district number
you know you look it up by your address
online whatever it is if you already
know your number then you can you come
in and you go directly to your ed yeah
you don't have that you can skip the
first set of tables to get your ETA
number right so stay people think she
means right then just go in there but
she meant was wait on line and just
skipped the first table or the other one
and all these people when the back of
line just rush up to the front door and
all the people at the front of the line
already were like whoa whoa whoa what
are you doing what are you doing and
then she out of nowhere just disappears
and all these people like where'd that
lady go she told us to come up here and
I was like walk and then me and Mary all
sitting there I'm trying to keep my
focus on like I have to I have to get
here out of here for my plane I'm
brewing out am I playing and then I am
like and she comes out and says some
other message I'm like I'm not believing
you lady because you just told us to go
up front and one supposed to go up front
and she looked at me like I was gonna
punch her in the face okay and then I
went in the polling place and people I
was so nervous I was gonna miss my plane
I'm like move move remember you really
do need a lot of work I do i go i go to
therapy i have it i think it's made me
worse than I've gotten better but I was
like this doing what do you mean you not
hit marielle was there like a secret
side of you no no I'm literally going to
this I think people and find it likes
people know people with direction to the
voting polls are like they're not paying
attention at all so I just go move go go
move move and this lady goes you know I
can't
until they move so you can't have you on
Tommy I go I'm not talking to you relax
and she goes she goes no you relax and I
go and then I tried to like calm
yourself down so go no you rely then she
didn't say anything about my arias I
don't know you relax yeah that's really
bad it's insane and then I got my I did
my stuff but it was still like a
[ __ ] I didn't cite entire cluster
[ __ ] it was really funny to marry om
Marielle oh I go well Mary all made fun
of me cuz when the lady when we're
outside and the lady came back out right
and I go she got married I'll start
making fun of me my wife started making
fun of it because I I yelled later I go
you know you really screwed the pooch on
this one like so they were walking back
to the apartment we're in a real hunter
now we won't make the apartment Muriel
goes it really screwed the pooch on this
one good like making fun school areas it
was really funny but it was fun i'm glad
i voted if you're like and then my wife
ran the marathon uh mrs. the other day
which was really exciting and it was
like oh I'm like this pretty awesome and
then but then when I went to go see her
like when you're walking up and then you
get into the street where they come down
I was like you get more and more excited
and then I waited around like about any
wait a couple of hours we waited about
an hour for her to get excited wanted to
make sure I was in the spot where she
was gonna pass and I didn't know how
there's a tracking they have an appt
with a track him and I were you standing
for that long I had some wings while i
was doing did you know but that's all i
saw aaron berger then he goes oh that's
great your wife you know Aaron we had em
on the play Ehrenberg go back in
previous episodes yeah and Erinn goes
will you your wife to the methods
awesome we were making funny at the
entire time last night and I go what do
you mean he goes we're like showing a
marathon with wings and I'm like okay I
can take that [ __ ] [ __ ] better hearing
my thing in my head like everybody is
saying the worst things about me at all
yes that's very self-indulgent no I
think other people think that way do I
think I think other people i know it's a
world song love really does it the best
advice ever is nobody thinking about you
as much
you're thinking about yourself yeah I
but I I still it's hard not to think
people are like yeah making fun of your
constantly I think people are but they
just don't do it in the way that you
think they're doing it I think like it
doesn't mean I here's what I think your
aims and I know you're talking [ __ ]
about me once a week Oh probably yeah I
know you talk to probably more than that
so no I don't talk [ __ ] about I talk
[ __ ] about you do I talk to you know I
just say you're sure you do to who Who
am I to talk to him and there are one of
our friends we won't we that'll be good
thing with my what do you say about me
when talking I just sound like when
people bring up your name is the same
[ __ ] that I've told you about I did it I
got it I go to people when they made me
people know you and they bring up your
name I go he's my bet he's like my best
friend but he's a [ __ ] nut yeah
that's why I say that's always that's
the only one I say I say it's crazy
right I try to commiserate over drift I
try to make them talk [ __ ] about you you
know hearing sounds like people or so
well even if they do I'm getting better
with that but they don't they don't it's
so funny because there we have certain
friends like we have mutual friends that
will probably talk [ __ ] about both of us
with that person like a bag ah this
[ __ ] pissed me off yeah that guy's an
[ __ ] and then if you do the same
think about me the big yeah he's an ass
oh yeah sure exactly oh that's that's
how [ __ ] talking works you're talking
super good we all talk [ __ ] it's fine
wats cathartic another dump thing i did
today I just started i'm running on
which i think i talked about superior
donuts on CBS coming out baby awesome
i'll come on i have primary march
hopefully is our friend Jermaine Fowler
is on a star of it he's the star of it
who my sister think it's as hot which is
a bizarre he's a track yeah yeah how
many Jermaine's why did your main um he
people caused your main st. Germain
which I don't know but it's just it was
the same name that's the point of that
but he goes on my facebook this isn't
anything dumb i did but i shouldn't
leave my facebook open cuz Jermaine will
just go on and write [ __ ] on my facebook
like he did yesterday I don't know if he
saw a status he wrote one yesterday was
like oh Lord fell in a sewer mine
confused
feet wet Lord helped the st. so we're
know it's rude man that that's something
you would write but I say is you're not
that far off hiding that I said uh i
blanked out of work today I wasn't
paying attention and I heard Shepherd
but I thought I said Matthew Shepard and
I go oh matthew shepard they go no Dax
Shepard this is a really okay I'd stop
the mood of the room where you bring up
that guy you just round tragedies oh
alright oh you mean the Holocaust yeah
well was it the Erica's do it seemed
ella grams house with the Hindenburg
it's like every we're just talking about
full I had to I had this moment today
which is a which I wasn't even like cuz
it's daylight savings time and I right
with this girl Emily she's written a
buncha she's really funny but I'm
looking outside and it's gotten a dark a
lot earlier um and she's like oh it's
duh it's dark yet and I go it's not dark
yet but it's getting there Bob Dylan
song I didn't realize it and she just
goes oh good she was right do we have a
what's this guys [ __ ] problem this I
mean when I had one that put that whole
thing was kind of the lady on the line
was kind of her problem and all right me
inside the place well I was you have one
well there's one woman here um when I
was home oh I have no so I can tell
about go ahead guys are you tires we all
right Mary all this was actually it was
freaking weird now I just thought of
this now so Marielle ran the marathon
and we all hung out afterwards in this
place st. st. John's gate it's like a
bar irish place on our side right some
got we're all drinking that's Mario's
Franks everybody's having a good time
some guy we met him in the beginning it
was like totally sober with his wife and
like we kind of like took over their
spot a little bit they were nice enough
to give Mary other chair so I kind of
like I bought on my puter cuz I was like
hey sorry for encroaching on your area
but ok this guy got he's from Riverdale
he led the Riverdale and the Bronx so
shit-faced and then all night would just
come over to us and come over to me in
particular
and they kiss my forehead kiss my
forehead and then like put me in a
headlock and just be like he shows are
you there's me in a dream state ya ain't
like he's like you know who loves you
who loves you who loves you I'm like you
do and then at one point he tried coming
over and he goes you know I'm not
supposed to tell you this but uh you
don't win my name is not chris you know
who i am and i go he told his name is
Chris and I go no who are you and he
goes I'm John duddy a professional boxer
and i'm a champ I'm doing my comeback
but you have to keep it you can't tell
anybody I'm here that's why I'm wearing
this hat yeah a hat on it was that real
is there John Dudley there is but it's
not him oh oh my god that's so crazy
[ __ ] nuts so then what happened once
and one he kept coming over and being I
probably thought that was a joke or
either you just correct right no he was
he started doing my shadow boxing like
socks me in the stomach any black who
loves you I love you John already John
Dalli I love you I don't I come back I'm
playing I'm fighting the management
garden in three weeks three weeks six
weeks I'm fighting mass regard I'm fine
I'm gonna come back and he's like guy
was like close to 50 years old like and
he's with his lady whatever and then
comes over one point licks my forehead
and that point it looks my phone I'm
like why but is really gross uh hurry
cities box so you can't fight him I
can't the guys like definitely a strong
guy like I think I'm wondering if he's a
boxer either I'm wondering if he's like
his name is John Donne he's just not
known where haven't known John Donnie
but he definitely had a boxer's body he
had like an older box about it and he
was doing shadow boxing like he was fast
like he knew what he was doing weird so
he kept coming over I'm like I'm like
he's like don't Tony book don't you tell
you don't I leave you can tell when I
leave and I'm like I'm not gonna tell
nobody should have thanked Boyd
Mayweather the no one is exactly so I go
and then he's like that's why I'm
wearing the Hat like nobody nobody's
recognizing you don't worry about it
then uh what happened was we leave and I
tell Maryellen oh my go I know he was a
professional boxer that's what it was
and then we go home and I look them up
and it's a guy not it's not him I know
you said yeah it's a guy that's like a
20 years younger than he is or 30 years
younger that's a weird box for a while
that is a son that's what I'm wondering
but
guys that guys from Ireland I don't
think this guy was from Ireland it's
crazy for that what's this guys [ __ ]
problem the guy who kept coming up
that's no that's no good it was not good
it was not good it was like the guy got
so shipping and then would have Oh on
the way out he starts pushing some other
guy and trying to get in a fight with
some other guy and the other guys like
her it was like they were so bulk so
drunk he's got nobody threw a swing
they're both just putting him like hey
and then the Box John daddy guy goes
what hey and then he was what hey and
then he goes are you pushing me stop
pushing me and he goes I just stared at
him and then just pushed him again it
was like crazy was a weird thing then
he's like I'm Manny Pacquio it's an old
Asian woman hey no one is what they see
here no one is what they seem yes that's
my story it's not super funny but it was
weird that had happened was I think was
entertained it's entertaining yeah
definitely you could have flipped it and
made the big reveal at the end but you
know I'm just I'm a storyteller I you
know why did that I didn't do that
because you mentioned the fact that I
[ __ ] it up you said that it wasn't um
what Apollo of this is our last episode
whatever what's going on your building
is there anything new uh oh no that dude
he was cleaned up the drug guy that
lease kid we I than the other guy join
the drug I got cleaned up but he's back
and he's back on heroin because he was
cleaned up and I saw him I owe this I
don't I said this in the podcast one day
I saw him and he was like oh those are
going I go how you doing he goes I'm
trying and he sounded normal and I'm
like oh he's trying he's trying to get
back on his feet and then I saw him
again he was totally out of it then the
other guy that was selling the paintings
in front of the building he one day
brought him food so I think the other
guy is an addict an ex-addict as well he
brought him food one day and it was like
I got a meal form and like his mom was
there was much grandmother whatever it
was so it was kind of it's a weird they
like I found out the guy the heroin guy
the guy who's got the [ __ ] out of me is
the grandson of the guy who used to be
the super of the building and they just
have support they've helped me pay 300
hours a month ago department and it's
probably a giant two bedroom apartment I
guarantee you I guarantee they're on the
same apartment as us for the obvious
the floors they probably have a size of
ours or like a two-bedroom a good
situation the consideration for them
that's what they have like six people
living it that's what these guys do
these people who've been their
neighborhood for like 30 years they
paying no money and then over that guy
Willie whatever his name is and he does
that program where the stage paying most
of his rent it sound like disability but
I'm wondering why don't know what the
deal is if I see him I haven't seen him
do any weird stuff Willie lately I just
I just wanna bring him food and I was
like oh he must that's nice that was
just nice that was like yeah yeah that's
it I was going on with the building and
then we're uh were we so we liked the
building a lot we like the neighborhood
a lot that's it that's that's kind of a
shitty conclusion of that whole thing
but yeah I wish I mother should happen
but it's kind of mellowed out a little
bit I I do we still have crazy as a dog
that this guy puts the muzzle on it that
literally tries to tear my dog's face
off every time you see them and keep
those dogs away from each other I do try
that and they these like they'll I don't
know where they'll be around a corner
and like it's not like that next job
just lunges every goal that it sees not
like like Cujo style like like like you
see the spit coming out of dog's mouth
like that kind of [ __ ] that I'm dealing
with I deal with that and I deal to the
guys dog that's like guys the [ __ ]
who you know accused me of not having it
all on the leash for a while I don't
well I'm here that seems like something
that you may have done I did do it yeah
exactly I did do it but a lot of these
what's this guys [ __ ] problem end up
turning back to you yeah I know these
guys this guy's crazy also it's not me
this guy's actually crazy because the
dog was also leash so much all the time
and then he tried to blame us for him
getting a summons from the building like
a thing like hey like I got like a
notice or whatever and if you talk
that's when he talked to mary l and i
was like no we're next time he talks to
you it just ignore me walk that yeah I
think that's the soy so it's a building
full of crazy people but it's very
diverse the neighborhood is pretty great
there's a lot of Muslims and there's a
Muslim people there's spanish people
there's there's everything there's every
different nationality this [ __ ] i feel
very progressive living there that's
that's what happened to the building you
know we're probably paying more than a
lot of people in the building but you
know it's worth it for
for what it is that's that's yeah and
Tom what's going on with you out here in
the Berkshires Tom are you having a
conniption fit right now because of the
Trump thing I won't get into it but
coming now shitties not vote for either
yeah did you not vote it all to order
for jill stein yeah no I thought I had a
lot of important things to vote on here
so you go for jill stein which we don't
eat me i would you vote on what month
the harvest is would you vote on what's
your name the apple cider has a wind
chime ordinance would you worry about it
because ya know I know you know them by
heart what was it yeah well that the day
of the Krampus parade you know that
we're gonna have lamp is like what is it
oh yes Santa it's our Krampus is like
evil Santa oh you're gonna have that I
don't depress the town is at this point
yeah we have that talk just won Ohio
teeny yeah um which is uh which is
expected so was it yeah you're not gonna
win Pennsylvania no he's not gonna win
Pennsylvania Jesus Christ all right well
this is I'm kind of a shitty last
episode four people were just reading
away I know I know I know oh yeah I'm
stop but we gotta go back to marry we
was poor planning our parking very hard
problem it's very hard not to do that as
we just interrupts go tom as far as
what's what's this guys [ __ ] problem
for me this wall it just happened i was
i was trying to park here as a pain the
ass get in here and and this woman there
was just enough spawn she was in her car
and there's a car in probably just
enough you sorry to interrupt you but
you have a lot of parking things going
i'm not a good driver oh no i'm not a
good driver right but I've always
admitted that but this is her fault um
where I I said where hey gonna move she
goes well yeah a little but not right
now and there's just enough for me to
squeeze in between hersha I've all she
do is back up a little bit fine [ __ ] it
I've done that where I don't want to
leave I'm gonna park in the middle takes
me forever to get in between her any
other car and then as soon as I'm park
she drives away what a piece of [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] that's on purpose that
on purpose and absolutely on purpose
right what a [ __ ] twisted [ __ ]
yeah anyway uh I don't like using the
word cut that's a giant negative giant
let this get what's his gal what's this
girls [ __ ] problem [ __ ] but she's
used to awful person so and you know
what guys I thought about last week I
know I actually got some hate mail for
more one in particular for what I for
what I did wait it was the female no no
the real facebook message from oh we
won't say her name but anyway hello
bready uh but uh no that was a real hate
mail that house rules a little bit no it
was notable well anyway the point is is
that I thought about a lot because I I
thought about it a lot and you know I
thought about well you know cuz I I
blamed all you guys and the reason the
show was ending index III did I thought
about it and I had to say I I still
think i was completely still blame all
of you on the show ending you know I
like my job but it would be great just
to do his podcast make enough money from
that and you know this is on you again
guys toss a little on my family and my
closest friends wait house well cuz they
didn't give a [ __ ] either i I'll tell my
print bag oh yeah we're at hundred and
seventy evel's 107a my mother [ __ ]
given was no one listened to what we
have some good guess my fee on my listen
to it my mom doesn't but my mama my mom
has in the past i'm always i don't
listen to it that's not one person I'm
like don't do it yeah she should not
miss my mom my sister's listen to it
things that you know oh hey Lori just
want Virginia oh no all right okay I
stop stop stop okay so we'll talk about
after uh one thing I will say one thing
you can tell that that nobody helps us
out is whenever you post a link to the
new episodes it gets my on my wall I'll
write something stupid about write some
corny whatever it'll get like 150 likes
and then all right hey check out the
numbers I realize like realize every
time i got i posted a picture of me at
denny's on instagram I don't even
many instagram powers and i got like a
hundred and twenty favorites for it i
post you know like I'm me on another
podcast or beyond the Nicki podcast way
more yeah yeah I'm then this this has
been and I feel like to that it's been a
double thing cuz you know the Nicki one
we're on hiatus now you know we're still
looking we're retooling [ __ ] but uh you
know that ended and then they came here
so now two men in a row but um well it's
fine I think we should be able to start
writing books like Phoebe Robinson we
have to do you can't touch my beard so
many I can't see I can't do the opposite
i can't be like so many so many so many
so many black dudes everyone would be a
good oh there's a whole nation money
white probably white guys so many black
guys oh my god what's going on here we
can be chewed up King yes just shared
okay Muto too doped jesters judo guys
who control the mote in the castle
that's it would be good you dopes your
jobs two dopes this is the only thing
yeah well don't lady well we should go
to the final hooter no final our final
our final mail Oh finally you have some
good ones Tom do we actually have a real
hate mail goes but you Scott with the
one you brought up but the face we have
had I have to I you know I should say
this I got two emails that I bike
[ __ ] i spaced on I gotta go get and
said to you guys but we got to really
nice emails one person someone who works
my dad and another person so there those
people thank you forget their names down
they what did they say they said they
will the podcast nurse at sending really
sorry works for your dad I got a couple
this is stage manager for my dad's plane
Ariel's friend Bianca Soto bachelor yay
[ __ ] I tried to mount that anyway yeah
yeah yes um she actually looks pot let's
pop her podcast she has a podcast about
hamilton called hamill cast yeah
and it's it's it's really really good
check out if you love it you love
Hamilton love you but let's like the
hottest layshia fan for a ver show yes
oh she is I wasn't gonna give her a plug
if she was well that's well we do it
anyway she um she's a fan of the podcast
and she I said that I saw her leo day
she came to the marathon to hang out
after at the bar and she was like bummed
out that sending so hello Bianca and
everybody listen to a hamel cast you can
get on iTunes you can get it online just
do a search for hamill cast they talk
about I think all things Hamilton
they've had some really great guests on
so yeah check it out and she's really
got her little exclua-o she does yep oh
that's awesome great did you draw a huge
hamilton pan oh yeah okay okay not the
musical the president we should treat
whether we go thank yous I want to hold
it at the end is there a Dido song thank
you thank you now that's more set oh
yeah thank you goes right guys yeah I so
should we do the mail what are you able
to the mail alright let's do er ye if
you have any hate me let's start off
with that cuz that'd be really great I
didn't I didn't get any hate mail Oh
Jimmy loves the show why are we yeah I'm
not everybody uh well the only thing
people to love it as people who show it
by not exactly that's funny people who
don't love it all right let's hear a
letter Tom do it out mmm here's
something that we're not going to end up
being able to do because we're ending
the podcast this is from John and we
heard the past president he had a
request for us to marry him and his wife
on the podcast oh but well where you
live John maybe we can do it in real
life are you we are you kidding me
really what did he say what's the
message say he's a great great podcast
have a great idea merius on your podcast
Oh licenses is like $25 if you don't
have the moolah will front you twelve
dollars good of course you're gonna
promise the melia use the money for I
did there's a fee that's awesome but
where's
oh my god that that could be damned
Minnesota to every movie quote he's ever
wanted to do Minnesota I'll goodness
well I have a here's John if you want to
hold it off I have a friend who's gonna
get married near Minneapolis and the
next probably within the next year and I
think I'm invited to that one wedding so
if you I can plan it around so I can go
to his wedding and then and then
officiate your guys so you wanted to do
it on the podcast well I'm time given in
the next best thing that's not the next
best thing first thing on the pocket
that would have been awesome huh has
ever been done before on a blog as well
as of course it is Aaron's like yeah
like seven hodding like you [ __ ] any
errands like it's totally fine this is
ending well what was the guy's name John
that's an awesome we're sorry we going
to that sorry John I'm actually gonna be
I'm gonna be Minneapolis as well in
February so if that's when Dan's going
we can decide who you'd rather would you
rather would you rather I would who's
miserable [ __ ] or would you rather a
really really sure guy a miserable
[ __ ] Samaria somehow made a marriage
with expect with experience of Mary J
somehow made a marriage all right what's
anything else anyhow cool like that that
was a big first one that was huge god I
wish we could do that yeah that would be
great I'll do we could do it here with a
whole ceremony in the video like right
there um that'd be great that really
helped surplice I not right in front of
them not even a visual joke just an
actual place wreck a visual direction am
looking right there they're all right
let's under the letter um let's see I'm
gonna step through these guys oh okay
well do this room until my eight no no
we don't what time oh nevermind yeah we
can do another half yeah we got yeah
we're good okay this is from Blair who a
male Blair so just mmm a guy way it's
possible it is possible i like blair
Underwood uh my active you know yeah I
know why he wrote you uh to say thanks
cuz he his friend the struggling
concerned Canadian who showed his
podcasts well this is another admitting
of a crime or like a sex crime were to
saw I do not want to hear
100 by you I'm dweb totally right on
that Tom if it is I'm not gonna [ __ ]
hear it that's what the numbers dropped
off so much because it's really arrested
for the crime yeah exactly i'm not gonna
have that guy with that weird [ __ ]
thing you know I just okay Tom I gotta
hit her sometimes you a shitty job
screening your real [ __ ] shitty job
well it's I'm trying to read around the
half written sentences that I got this
is why we don't [ __ ] have him
Christopher fog as we all these [ __ ]
alisnar I'm for Kennedy waterheads
that's what they're called all right
well I'm jugheads this retards it's not
like a slang for black people go ahead
Tom let's see let's hear this
masterpiece yeah it sounds like a real
[ __ ] [ __ ] show already let's give
this Shakespearean go ahead he loved
that we ripped on his Canadian friend in
episode 150 ah uh and he loves the show
and everyone involved and to keep it up
so this is before he got the news I
myself AM I'm also an overweight bearded
fellow so he kills identity with you
nicely guys once Tom certain the pic
little blood says i love the Tom
struggles hope you guys are doing great
let's take let's take a look at that
message dan and Sean are fat and I loved
Tom struggle I wonder how that made it
to the top of the [ __ ] message with I
don't know that I learn I think you're
reading into it go ahead we're alone
thank you very much what's his name
again the guy Blair Thank You Blair I'm
not a real actor as you said yeah I said
where's black whatever ah thank you so
much next ha and do you want me to read
the message uh from Katie that was gonna
directed to you there's sure ok sister
um hey guys said this is so you feel
better I guess hey guys I've written to
you before talking about how super
studly I find Dan to be but I wanted to
write again after listening to your life
and Todd's burying the [ __ ] thing I
was wrong
I'm sorry sorry sorry let me start by
saying this is love small decks I'm like
wait what let me start by saying that
this isn't like a girl power rant or
anything but come on you don't really
believe that you don't have any cute
female listeners do you I like to pride
myself for being mildly attractive I
adore you guys we're not all [ __ ] shoe
crazed maniacs a little food every
picture of myself as well can we ask can
we first up I don't think we've ever i
know i did call a woman a [ __ ] earlier
than podcast but for the most part
that's not I know it's not they know
it's not like this yeah we don't think
that yeah we're very progressive on this
pocket yeah even though we look like two
[ __ ] Trump supporter go ahead so uh
she she says I'll include a picture of
myself as photographic evidence of my
cuteness and it is she is well it passes
I think furthermore I can't believe you
came to Maine without visiting me Tom
that was during my main trip and uh and
lastly I would totally peg Dan like
[ __ ] good 20 and pegging whoa what
you want to describe my packing is it's
gettin it's gettin [ __ ] in the butt
with a dildo dildo by a girl but way
ladies have to be a strap-on um yes it
has to be right yeah now Dan the
question is will Dan do this I don't
know I think by the time I'd get back to
Maine again hopefully I have a lady
friend or something but you know the
options always open um Kate Katie I'm
very flattered and who knows maybe I'll
be magically pegged by you at some point
ajik Lee though or maybe this is
evidence for when I murdered you turn to
a unicorn yeah yeah yeah uh well thank
you katie for leaving me actually begged
me with a magical flute that's how it
happens you should come out what's it
called a matador what do they call those
man torque no matter what only call the
have a center Center all right the scent
or I thank you for including me at all
in that email I've never you always get
cold studly and I do I ever get cold
it's always like the Bears the gay bears
that I've gotten cold hot bi gay bear on
my Instagram I have a lot of gay bears
that follow me on instagram and their
comment on my well we yeah we have one
that works both yes yes shut out a cook
[ __ ] it he's a great guy hugs a great
guy I do i do get bummed out though cos
ed cook certainly as a type cuz I'll be
like oh I'd cookie yeah yeah yeah then
I'll Wilkin it's just like all these
colors yeah one time I said I was like I
should have myself or something and
somebody wrote i believe i said this
from the pockets just so you know in our
community you're actually pretty hot oh
my god here in Mars and I'm kind of like
we walk on our hands and clap with our
feet and find you attractive and I was
like one doesn't help me out at all but
the appreciated ah anymore there Tommy
Boy I got a bunch I go for it man Kelly
uh who wrote to us to we I think we were
talking about stuff going on with each
other i mentioned that my daughter
started rowing she thought that was
awesome she says don't be naked about
your daughter's growing she said that
was cool and she's that she said that we
always make her our commute to work a
little bit better just a little bit and
she's fully hard you're like my mom
every little it's great and a funny
thing is that tom thinks that we don't
notice it that's the whole areas tamil
say something shitty at the end of it
and like you know Tom when you do that
me and Sean immediately call each other
and talk [ __ ] right like whenever you
like put one of your [ __ ]
passive-aggressive all the enemies
you'll be completely honest Tom Tom
messaged me over a couple days ago I
guess over the week what it was today
alright and about the Instagram account
I'll be and I didn't tell you this time
but I should have told you he told me he
sent me attacks that just said I've been
logged out of the Instagram account and
my first thought was you thought that we
did it that we locked you out
ro yeah oh you didn't think that I know
I realize you probably didn't think that
but that was my first dog that's how I
that's how it sounded to me can I was
like wait what and then I thought about
like you started the have the info for
it so I couldn't even have done it but I
was like oh [ __ ] he's like thinks that
were like blocking him out of all this
my dumb friend enough and that wasn't
the case I thought I most pathetic power
play I know I know that's not I know
that's not the cast other case but ya
know I just thought that we'd been
hacked and then ya know we would imagine
when Assange went after us yes the
rushee leaks I do like your level Tom
but I we do pick up every time that you
see something like yeah you're not
exactly master of subtlety that's good
it's good well she's heartbroken that
the podcast is is ending and she
personally apologizes to Dan on behalf
of this unappreciative audience I
appreciate that and you know what if
there are more people like you then
maybe I'd be doing it but not enough
people apologize so um got plenty I
really well and as a child what is that
me I just want to end this is like just
the biggest child ever just really is
petty I don't think you guys are sorry
you know alright uh give me more letters
yeah yeah Alex rights to us he says
greetings from Athens Greece so he he's
wanted to say thanks for making it
literally that's pretty crazy yeah it's
pretty amazing he wanted to say thanks
for making him look like a maniac
laughing to himself during train rides
to work and he said that the podcast is
is ending mom well see i should yield
the economy of your country now figure
that given the double bird to every one
of our fans that emails yeah we're gonna
do other podcasts and nobody's gonna
carry over to those i guess haha did did
you want me to read the one for Brandi
no yeah you can read it are you really
good well I don't know yeah I think you
do you think we should read it uh yeah
sure you can read it I mean she read it
she sent it to the Facebook account
yeah yeah she's she's I mean what do we
want to you want me to give you the
whole oh we won't give the whole last
name or anything no no not the last name
but ok so this is from brandy seat she
said so I'm just gonna [ __ ] on Dan for a
minute first of all [ __ ] you dan I
really loved you on not safe haha i gave
your podcast a chance and listen to
every [ __ ] episode even though I
hated you on here good I only continued
to listen because Tom and Sean [ __ ] on
you occasionally welcome so it's a
minute you should I Dan a lot yeah i got
i get a lot of abuse so let's take a
minute to appreciate them and all their
work so now and she says now fans of you
guys i was even trying to once contain
my disappointment but could no longer
confront you and wrote a note to myself
about why i should listen to the podcast
I mean who thought it would be okay to
make damn the star also like when he was
on his silent retreat that was a good
podcast haha but here's the thing that
is that are you go ahead the whole head
right I didn't think that I would even
am sorry come on I don't think I would
have even said any of this [ __ ] if Dan
wasn't such a dick in the last episode
uh let's see what is hell so Dan respect
your loyal listeners and co-hosts
without them you'd only have six
listeners ah brutal um but oh and then I
take it takes a turn at some point
doesn't it and then she then then
there's a pause and then it comes back I
don't know I'm sorry I listen to this
episode after an awful date where I
drank too much so if Dan still wanted to
touch me I wouldn't say no haha talk
about all of the usual suspects and
letters and then to make it even better
this girl is cute I bet that's what
about the same so it turns out the whole
time she was just negging dan yeah this
goes super hot super hot I cannot be
more disappointed that this is what
happened with that letter that is the
worst ending to the best really
all right good penance Sean and Tom I
like you more maybe you should start
your own podcast together she's still
nagging that's negative isn't it yeah Jo
it's great guy guys all right let's love
you all and then the next day she goes
wow this is why you don't drink alcohol
but oh that was her yeah okay that's
like show something I think at one point
I wrote back this really took a turn
like after yeah you did you did and I
wrote me grant one look at me but she
yeah she did she uh she's super super
hot she's super hot I was so mad that it
went that way at the end did at the end
of it it was like damn it did but uh
thank you for giving us a little bit of
joy in that the first two-thirds of that
letter and they give her the last third
and yeah and and and we're sorry we're
ending we apologize but you know Brandis
you know every podcast we do we both
have albums on itunes and listen we'll
do that at the end we're not done with
the bucket of messages yet yeah I just I
just have a few more so let me hammer
through these uh this is from from night
shift Clayton Clayton oh I got to that
one yeah that was great said hey this is
night shift Clayton I wanted to let you
all know that you'd become my favorite
podcast and they've come to look forward
to this is the one who wants to [ __ ]
Sean he is that one good night shift I
don't know why I'm so excited he really
does he Wow I became to look forward to
listening to you guys tell stories in
[ __ ] with each other over the past
year especially came to love hearing Tom
telefon ting realizations which really
made my life feel a little less bleak by
contrast ah you will be sorely missed
every week I truly mean that I hope you
all continue podcasting on your own
project sincerely night shift Clayton PS
Tom likes almost as many of my facebook
updates as my mom yeah what's the deal
tom I don't know he he friended me and I
reality other day goes she was Tom likes
all my stuff on like yeah yeah he's
friendly person
oh yeah yes he does that he's being
friendly did you see something you said
something this week that was uh it made
me nervous you there's some facebook
status update Tom ad oh is that you ever
laugh alone and cry yeah it was a dark
or something [ __ ] cloud never cry
alone on a clown of the doctor IRAs now
it goes like to like sounds the best
part of it yeah we took over your
facebook Heath Ledger during the Dark
Knight um alright so a couple more this
is from Ashley Ashley what a lot of we
gave to do a hot sounding girls
yesterday bill Oh Ashley maybe a boy
right yeah this one's a girl um she lets
see she's new to listening to podcasts
in general no way a wasn't some good
ones we get a lot of it yeah I normally
listen to podcast I tried yours out and
then they disappeared as gone yeah I go
ahead sorry she says I'm from the
Northeast but I'm now living in [ __ ]
South Dakota so I really missed the
obscene language and ripping on one
another from back home everyone out here
is quote serial killer nice nice if you
asked me just wanted to say hi and love
you guys style thanks for the laughs
laughs actually by ash said sent with
love goodbye inside like she was you
slowly let's put your sleep this is this
is for for dan from Pattin a question
for din I grew up in pound ridge and was
arguing with my friend that grew up
there as well about who had better pizza
moonstruck or dinardo's your vote will
help settle this God dinardo's well
Gennaro's yeah i would say dinar does is
better i was a very definite I like two
moons try I like the black cherry soda
they had a moonstruck but I think that
it if you really want to get done pizza
ington or is just a better Italian
restaurant I know you guys moved in
there you go patent patent this is from
rose and Amelia so here's one for your
stupid male back we do a podcast called
two girls one film and some time ago we
asked our Twitter followers
to give us film recommendations Tom
tweeted us bad man the girls yeah we got
there there there but great Tom treatise
back and told us to watch Big Trouble in
Little China for our next podcast
episode we watched the suggested film
for the first time I would you tell two
girls to watch big trouble it's removing
and what they say they have ambitions to
fly to the US and hunt Tom down and
punch him repeatedly in his groin it was
one of the worst podcast episodes we get
everyone how is Tom making pockets of
those words from across the pond
hilarious we just talked about how much
of a wanker tom is for about two hours
they are really there the British on and
Dan hi they're awesome anywho we just
wanted to ask Dan and Sean with their
top three favorite films are so we can
secretly judge them oh I love that one
actually wanted I want to do them i
don't really well um I you know I don't
know my top three are of all time so I
can't really answer that but I'll tell
you three movies that I've the recent
three movies I can watch over and over
again Are All the President's Men slap
shot and zodiac those three movies I can
watch on repeat I don't know if I'm I
sell your favorite no not my favorites
but those are just three to pop up to
zodiac might be one of the most
underrated moderated Shh I don't know I
think something happen with the politics
of it when it came out yeah and that is
one of the best movies i've ever seen
it's not my favorite overall yeah but
it's unfuckingbelieveable that movie
it's so good ah right so what do you say
you three you're gonna give them our
slap shot yeah I just say that those are
movies that i can watch like all that oh
and i watched no country the other day
like that i can watch anytime no
countries in my top three favorites yes
right so no country for old men i guess
all time I'd have to say good fellows
but it was good fellows because I it's
literally been in the lifetime challenge
dad's I I totally great you know I was
like it's so bad that we really just
can't it's like when you watch the
sopranos on a any or something you're
like ooh yeah it's it's it's so it's
really good but it's a
it's so good it's like it's probably the
best movie of all time but like I've
seen it so much and it's been I've seen
every different version of it we r AG
and you know so much about it you're
right I don't know what about that
you've seen goodfellas listen to this
part but you know the whole thing with
Tommy getting killed in goodfellas yeah
that we were done with this you know did
that real life who John Gotti oh really
he met later but they could Lee they
couldn't put in the book because he was
still like mafia boss John Gotti's the
one who shot him really yeah Oh in that
crazy that's crazy and then my third uh
I would problem I i did this online
recently my third I third I probably put
singing on the rain is really is really
never zoom it's really good I think
people think it's like just a musical
and it's goofy women it's super is
actually super funny like it's actually
the jokes are great in it and it's and
it's like fun to watch and the music's
good and so singer we watch you know I
was just watching old cheers episodes
again last year's is unbelievable they
saying cheers is the perfect pilot
that's what they say you when you write
a pilot supposed to read the cheers
pilot and goes good Roseanne's a really
good pilot too Roseanne is an
unbelievable show so I just watch the
episode on the plane right over here uh
cheers but that was funny that show was
funny pretty much the whole way through
yeah I don't think they really although
jokes are very different now what you
don't you can really make like like with
the opening a cheers it was just a joke
it was it was just like kind of a joke
and then the rest the episode in really
needed to do its job the color white
yeah I like oh oh oh yeah they actually
do that more on cable shows now than
they do yeah you're right oh yeah I had
no issue with that what's wrong it's not
cool yeah I liked it all up ah next are
some movies uh that and they close with
loving the show especially enjoy the
segment that guy's a dick or whatever it
is oh wait do I go out if you can
[ __ ] remote school what's this guys
[ __ ] problem won't one then they saw
so great oh wait no our favorite
segments is Tom's realization of the
week all right next one the next one all
right Dan relax
okay hey a couple minutes oh yea what
aim was to get out of here no I don't
want to get out of here all right what's
the next letter there tom another one
from Katie not another one from Katie
but this next one is from Katie not even
done listening to this week this week's
podcast but heard you break the farmer
news about ending it she wants to thank
us for hours and hours of satisfying and
genuinely hilarious entertainment yours
is my favorite podcast him hands down
anyway she loves us in that we will we
will leave a void in her life all right
Beverly says can't believe we're ending
the podcast but hope to hear us in the
soon and yes we have girl you have girl
listeners I am one and let's I have one
you are nothing this is from bill I
don't know if I'm gonna read that one
Josiah yeah yeah basically I did more
people [ __ ] on other progress no
just it's [ __ ] on [ __ ] on us uh
yeah I say that God well it's mainly
[ __ ] on Dan so here we go hahaha
that's final so old Saint Germain is
getting too big in his britches for the
world of he podcasting and would prefer
to get a job instead that comes with
health and dental insurance oh no he's a
comma yeah the three of you are just too
funny to die a sad death in the iTunes
podcast basement but if it must be it
must be if i may just humbly make a
final request and that request is that
Tom's official status on the podcast be
elevated to that of hosts even if it
just if even if it is just that of a
symbolic gesture on the last episode
sort of like how you would make a small
child an honorary police officer for a
day that's really funny while giving him
a fake police badge is honest yeah
Thomas [ __ ] that you had made with the
department office printer haha Sean with
you for the great podcast and Godspeed
bill I want to do that but I'm nervous
the message it would send
so I'm gonna say no Tom you're good
where you are you know that oh my god
the last podcast all right what do you
think you think I think yes I thought
that's I think I think we really it is
how about junior host we call junior
hose Thomas Jr host I think we have to
realize is Tom's been a host this entire
time a note from Melissa who she says
[ __ ] you you dumb mother [ __ ] I've
listened to every episode am episode of
mdf in addition to every podcast that
has featured you guys I work in a shitty
cubicle where some mornings the only
thing keeping my eyes open is this
[ __ ] podcast I have told everyone to
listen to this hilarious podcast i have
shared I've retweeted I've donated and
you three can't spare one [ __ ] hour of
his busy week to sit on the phone
attached it far off from what we have
now if you just recorded a three-way and
released it make phone call dan I know
how your mind tends to go all wild
things I'm truly an odd that this
podcast has so few listens I baffled
that someone would rather hear Apple
chatter or dogs jerking off then listen
to the listen and laugh with you three
when I first heard this bogus
announcement I was sad she just shat on
my other podcasts but that's time to not
say but haha that's hilarious um let's
see but I way if I ever moved to LA we
can do the podcast I mean maybe i'll try
giving people hope now i'm found a
wonder Sean's already thinking that he's
already got plans in the works guys just
in case you didn't know Sean's got plans
in the works he's told me about so let's
see she says so I'll leave you with this
every week I take about 15 to 20 of my
family and friends phones and I
downloaded this podcast i also
downloaded it to three of my own demo
she did not every funny though if like
we even had less listeners like they're
like u2 album
she says so that low low number of
losers who listen weekly is actually
even lower than yeah and we got this
gone she be a guest in the podcast yeah
thanks much yes enclosed a climate he
has enclosed as a token of my love and
going away gift and she did do a
donation ten dollars for sean's chicken
strips ten dollars for dance chick
strippers and ten dollars for Toms 401k
haha this is funny she could be very
funny good job Melissa that was great
she's great uh what's he chester wrote
to us to say thanks she used her you
casper will you a mannequin Esther the
mannequin Chester he's been a huge fan
for years and let's see you guys have
continually introduced me to great
comedians hopefully tom will start
recording his haunting realizations and
putting those out and Sean can do the
same with his what's this guys [ __ ]
problem since that seems to be his
specialty thanks for the great memories
and laughs let me know if you guys ever
come out to Chicago was awesome seeing
Sean at zanies a few months back nice
thank you for coming see thank you for
coming the xanies dude let's see what is
the one watch we do one more how many
more are there how many more there I
there's just one like one more oh god I
didn't read it damn Jesus this from
Jason that kills me you guys are
canceling my dumb friends and the huge
tragedy is the loss of the comedy duo of
Dan and Sean together it's just solid
gold you to feed off each other so well
the banter is like none other please
make sure you continue working on comedy
together and so we do have something on
the side and maybe something will happen
with it that'd be great if it did we
have something we have something in the
works that's not a hundred percent yet
but hopefully you'll be fine about soon
if we if that does come to fruition we
will that's what we'll do we'll do an
episode right okay yeah i mean there is
have something it'll that your feed your
feet will stop but hopefully I'll if you
get a weird episode downloaded one time
it's the
talk about that yes we happy and if not
it means we're really unsuccessful
hahahaha yes I don't hold your breath
we've gotta there's a few donations this
last week i think is a i don't know what
they were trying to keep us going we
have all my donations were there just a
number of donations not how much I feel
but loving like like half a dozen or so
that's great that's great thanks yeah so
thank you all time you bought him a UH
we find out it's like a hundred thousand
dollars right guys Thank You Christopher
and William and I think you know what
that means I think it's time for Toms
haunting realization of the pod cast oh
I'm gonna do it you want to do it Tom's
ever Tom's most haunting realization
Tom's haunting realization I just want
to apologize everybody I'm facebook par
batatis today I tried to get her call in
she's m.i.a so uh what's just as soon as
I really wish is just saying but Tom and
got rid of her number do you want to
know I [ __ ] up and I do you want to
tell everybody what Tim Dylan wrote us
about barber tapesh know a nice one of
her status in years he wrote thank you
for bringing this woman to my life
because it was like a pro Trump rape it
was insane she's a [ __ ] lunatic all
right next up all right tom let's see so
we're coming up on the Christmas season
and we're getting bombarded in the house
for you know upgrades and updates to
various video games that we have in the
house and you know my son wants for us
to get these I mean we don't have call
of duty but we have you know a couple
others and and you know you as a parent
you keep hearing about the effects of
video games on kids and you know I'm
kind of from one of the earlier video
game generations and I'm like I don't
you know
whatever happened with video games and
me you know and and I didn't really
think anything had happened until I
remembered that's this thing that
happens in college there was a thing we
would do I lived in these kind of dorms
that were near the beach and what would
happen is there'd be these parties at
the beach like these frat guys would go
and have parties at the beach you know
and drag you know wood pallets out there
and burn them off and and it was always
like a huge mess like kind of right
outside where we lived with garbage and
cups and all this stuff weekend and week
out and we started doing this thing
where we would sneak down to the the
party that was happening while these
people were maybe passed out around
their fire and we would take the tap off
the keg and sneak out and back into the
darkness and then turn the tap in at the
keg shops for money and we went by this
one party and it was still kind of going
but we thought we would be smart and
sneak up on the party and I grabbed the
keg my friend took the tap off of it and
there was still some a bit of beer of
the keg but me thinking oh I can I can
manage with this I started carrying it
off and the people at the party noticed
she's not a yet it was not it was not
good so somebody starts yelling and
these people start running towards us
and I'm running with the keg as fast as
I can after my friend who just took off
because he was just carrying the tap and
at Santa Barbara there these Bluffs with
these big staircases that go down to the
beach these big wooden kind of zigzaggy
staircases and I'm running up the
staircase as fast as I can with this
heavy keg these guys are gonna catch me
like this bat pack of frat guys are
gonna beat the [ __ ] so I but I managed
to get near the top and I'm like what am
I going to do with this keg there's no
way I'm going to get away I think
they're going to catch me so I turned
around and lifted
The Keg up and I hold it down the stairs
like donkey I don't call him so and
there were screams I did manage to get
away but why there were screams what
have you do you just admit to a murder
this is what's happen on his podcast and
Tom and mr. he erased and he murdered a
bunch of frat guys in Santa Barbara
California I hope wait right when we
could have avoided working at up by the
last I heard the keg clanging around and
you know maybe the thud of it hitting
some bodies as I like ran ran off and I
was just I was like oh my god I just
Donkey Kong them and so yeah definitely
I don't think we're gonna be getting
these video game updates like son cuz I
don't want I don't know what's gonna
happen ten years from him oh so you
think you're dining on them because you
played so much donkey kong yeah that's
what it was like just put it together I
didn't even try to save your ass I bet
seems yeah like a pro thing that's like
you know what it wasn't my favorite last
haunting realization but I will say this
you came out on top of it it was the
first one yeah and that's what's good
about it yeah that's the happy ending
that we needed for the Tom's haunting
realizations because some of them were
[ __ ] doozies that one about the job
but the jerking off somebody mentioned
it to me yeah yeah ok that was the one
of the funniest [ __ ] things overheard
my life ah well I mean before we um
before we go I just want to thank all
things comedy for having us on this
network it's been animated cast homes
and I want to thank i want to i want to
thank Aaron and Al and Mike and Scott
and everybody at the All Things family
for that I want to thank Phil Pickens
who did our song and also you know he's
back in the studio again so you can
check that out I want to thank uh I want
to thank I mean more so than anybody
else I do want to thank Tom Tommy did an
amazing job with his podcast you dealt
with a lot of my edits you dealt with a
lot of Sean not emailing back and that
was passing haha but yeah the old a lot
of [ __ ] Tom and I know you know is for
as much [ __ ] as I give you your heart to
always been in the right place and I
want to thank all the amazing guests
we've had on here and I want to thank
sean for doing this with you I'm gonna
miss I'm gonna miss doing this with you
man yeah I want to thank I'm in the same
vein I don't think everybody for
listening uh thank you all things comedy
thank you Tom you're you really did you
turn the pockets around you all those
listeners that you read off and their
letters and stuff you got them to listen
to us because of your due diligence and
getting the word out about the podcast
and we should on you relentlessly but we
love you and yeah thanks Phil for doing
the thing and all the other things oh
thank you Dan said and yeah thank you
Dan this was a lot of fun and we're
still going to be friends in real life
so if you want to hear us argue just
call our cell phones will put you on
speaker and yeah I guess I guess this is
goodbye it's never goodbye
I used to say I live my life a quarter
mile at a time and I think that's why we
were brothers as you did too no matter
where you are or two quarter mile away
halfway across the world you'll always
be with me you'll always be my brother
wait so I'm polo I die why these on this
situation I'm just a better Vin Diesel
than you let's be honest and Tom is
there anything you want to say hey shut
up Tom no don't honestly Tom did you
want to plot anything no I shut up Tom
have a good night everything
[Music]
hi Tom our and happy thanksgiving to you
and Dan my dumb friends podcast I'm so
grateful although this Thanksgiving I'm
being bullied because I'm a trump
supporter but that's okay because oh
I'll see Democrats and even some
Republicans Oh anti-trump and they are
so secret and private and addicted to
their political correctness they hardly
know who they are their secret to
themselves so I wonder if they can be
grateful for anything as Christmas
anyway you want me to send us on a fan
wants to sing me I'm grateful I have the
balls to sing about just miss it
spontaneity 2012 on taneous for instance
you might be interested in this song we
I want to be free from limitation where
are we done limit or emotions the
Chimera free from England for drama too
we can't hide you trivia and it takes is
risking the truth I decided recently
always to cast are you make trouble for
sale
well succeed at least an open quickly
regardless what folks from me also
influenced sobbing because unlimited
emotion is happening to me learning to
be free from pinger is the greatest
level unlimited emotion is the hardest a
noble learning to this race on ego will
roll over
[Music]
[ __ ] you guys for giving bubala my phone
number
Mary was a boxer Lucy have to beat the
world
[Music]
whooping South Georgia
she used to beat up all the girls know
you not go
you